-This is a fascinating
documentary
that was about something
that happened,
which was this
Hulk Hogan Gawker trial...
-Yeah.
-...which basically
bankrupted Gawker,
but then the issues in it
have sort of become
a little bit more important now
maybe even than they were then.
But tell us a little bit
about what got you started
on this story.
-Yeah, I mean, I was
really, really interested
in this case,
this sort of trial between
Hulk Hogan and Gawker Media.
I just thought it was
interesting by itself.
You know, this was the first
time a sex-tape case like this
had ever gone to trial.
-So they had -- They basically
put the sex tape online.
-Yeah, so, Hulk Hogan was filmed
having sex with the wife --
-The key to a sex tape.
-With the wife
of his then-best friend,
Bubba the Love Sponge...
-Right.
-...who is a shock-jock
radio deejay in Florida.
So, this tape gets out there.
A lot of people
speculate about it.
There's some stills
posted I think on --
Maybe on TMZ and some other --
The Dirty or something.
And then eventually Gawker posts
an edited-down version of
this tape, along with a post.
And that starts
this really lengthy
kind of trial,
this battle between them.
-And during the trial,
Hulk Hogan made a distinction
between the character
of Hulk Hogan
and his actual --
the actual guy, Terry Bollea.
-Yeah.
-And because part
of what Gawker argued
was that they published
this sex tape
because it refuted things
that Hulk Hogan had said
about his own sexual prowess.
Is that correct?
-Yes, and this was a defense
that the Hogan team brought.
It was new to this trial.
They hadn't even mentioned this
in the previous
incarnations of this,
where they made a distinction
between Hulk Hogan
and the private person,
Terry Bollea.
And it was fascinating.
I mean, basically
their argument --
They said, "Look, you've
talked about this sex tape --
this sex incident many times
on Howard Stern's show,
in fact,
in very graphic details.
So why is this so private?
You know, you've actually
brought this into the public.
You've made it newsworthy
yourself."
And he said,
"Well, that's different.
That was me as Hulk Hogan
bragging about my sex life,
and that's different
than me as Terry Bollea."
And they actually
asked about his --
I don't know if you can
say this -- 10-inch penis.
-Yeah. Once you say "10-inch,"
they're gonna finish it.
Yeah.
-And so that actually
becomes a thing.
And Hulk Hogan on the trial,
or Mr. Bollea, says,
"Actually I don't have
a 10-inch penis.
Hulk Hogan does.
But me, not so much."
-This is a crazy --
This sounds like
just the craziest trial.
And then Hulk Hogan wins
this $50-million settlement.
Was it 50?
-It's $140 million.
-$140 million. My goodness.
-Yeah, well, I mean,
that was the initial verdict.
-And so that bankrupts Gawker.
Now, one of the things
that's interesting is, you know,
there are a lot of people
that would say
Gawker made some
editorial choices
that were sort of beyond
what is considered
journalism with dignity.
But ultimately the question is,
do you also have to
protect the free speech
or the rights to the free press
when they're doing things
that you don't agree with?
Is that the fear of press
going forward,
is that Gawker basically
was put out of business
by this one decision
and that other people will use
this same technique to take down
any website or any news sources
that they don't like?
-Yeah. I mean,
you're completely right.
It's a complex story, and I
think that's one of the reasons
why I personally found it
so compelling.
It's not an easy story.
I think I kind of
found it interesting
'cause it's difficult
in some ways
and it is on the edges
of acceptability with speech.
It's a little like
"The People vs. Larry Flynt"
kind of territory.
But that dramatic verdict
that actually silences Gawker
and then the revelation
that Silicon Valley investor
Peter Thiel
was actually bankrolling
Hulk Hogan's case
the entire time in secret,
that made it a very
kind of different story.
It became a story about
how big money can silence
critical voices.